while concern for parents at a local
elementary school after a case of
tuberculosis pops up that School jet
strip Elementary is located near Lindell
and Tropicana 8 news now reporter Brian
will found out what this means for
students and how you can keep your
family safe
this is the letter that was sent home to
parents on Tuesday triggering mandatory
tuberculosis testing today and I spoke
to a doctor today who says tuberculosis
is more severe in young children
it's one of the ancient scourges of
mankind and it's still around it's still
with us tuberculosis is a bacterial
disease that is spread through the air
and can cause serious health concerns
according to Pediatric infectious
disease Doctor David DeJean tends to be
actually more severe in young children
especially infants or those less than
four years old but it can be severe in
anyone Dr DeJean says what is most
important is early detection but when
you have an outbreak situation or a case
in a school then you really have to be
more careful you have to find out about
risk factors in individuals you have to
do testing and then you have to let
patients know the Southern Nevada Health
District is charged with ensuring the
community's safety and making sure those
exposed get notified and tested for
those people who received the
individualized letters saying that they
were and they were exposed going and
getting that testing done as soon as
possible is highly recommended the
results because it is a blood test the
results take a couple of days to go and
we will contact people with their
results regardless of whether they're
positive or negative Dr DeJean says to
look for these symptoms even if
vaccinated if you develop a cough a
fever or other more severe symptoms
night sweats losing weight just kind of
feeling lousy and you've been exposed
you probably need to see your health
care provider and be tested
on the Clark County School District
hasn't said whether it was a student or
adult who tested positive for
Tuberculosis but they are testing
students here again in March reporting
in Spring Valley Brian will 8 news now
Brian thank you for that now if you or
your child start showing any symptoms of
TB you are encouraged to get a TB test
right away